But a matrix, you know a matrix, I mean, you know what it looks like.
We've already seen it.
matrices are denoted like
so
so for example
to the power and
times that
so for vectors, we have raised to
one particular power that will give us a sequence of an element
so five elements in one set and a matrix obviously
is a set of sets.
so it can be
a set with five elements in three rows
So what this could look something?
like this
keep it.
So in matrices do we indicate the number of rows first
or the number of columns?
What would n be here?
And what would M be?
So n is the number of rows so we have two rows and three,
so that's what we mean by by.
you know R to the power n times m
two rows
with three columns
and I hope you can be you know, it's probably self-explanatory. What
a column space is. We said we've already established that there was space
being set.
So the column space for the Matrix, let's indicate this
Matrix with the letter m.
Okay.
Once again, we want to make sure it's bold letter. So
PF.
So the economic space of M would be what that sets
of columns.
So we will get a vector 2 6 a
vector one. Five a vector one negative 3
And then the row space would be well two one one and
six five negative 3.
That's it.
That's all the row space and column space are.
and of course, this is supposed to be real sorry
and of course column space would be all of the
the sets that make up the row in in
The Matrix sound.
Okay, so, oh we will
use this glossary.
So that we can you know easily.
And talk about anything to do with matrices neural networks.
3D plots
And every time we use words like this, we know what we're talking about.
All right.